evident delight for german socialist mep
matthias quarter who's had a mighty slog
to push through changes to europe's
emissions trading system it's floundered
under depressed prices recently now meps
have agreed to delay the issue of new
carbon certificates to squeeze demand
and drive up or at least stabilize
prices but it's just the first small
step we need really structural forms we
need a dynamic component in the emission
trading system a steering effect
to a really low carbon economy and low
carbon society
and this year's looks prize parliament's
award to european filmmakers goes to the
broken circle breakdown
it's a crazy love story it's um it's
about a belgian banjo player who meets
his beautiful tattoo artist and although
they're very different they just click
and then we see how they six years later
have a daughter who is a beautiful kid
but starts to get ill the movie is
asking you know when you go through such
difficult times will love stand
mr schultz praised all three nominated
filmmakers for feeding the political
process with a rare commodity ideas
politically referenced
a small but significant victory for
parliament which has been demanding the
final say on appointments to the
european court of auditors the body
which oversees eu accounts meps argue
they're a better guarantor than member
states of the independence and
professionalism necessary in candidates
for the job
m